kidbi happy Halloween ich bin eine
Katze heute ist Halloween und was passt
besser zu Halloween als Harry Potter
mein Kanal wäre nicht mein Kanal wenn
wir nicht auch dieses Jahr einen Harry
Potter Adventskalender Auspacken würden
aber das Besondere dieses Jahr ist es
der originale Wizarding World
Adventskalender ich hatte schon ein von
Boots ich hatte schon einen
selbstgemachten von aber ein
og
Adventskalender das wird toll und da ihr
dieses Video schaut wohnt ihr
wahrscheinlich in Norddeutschland habt
morgen nicht frei und seid nicht auf
irgendeiner Halloween Party unterwegs
Süddeutschland ist ja ja irgendwie ganz
special die haben immer am 1 November
Tag der aller
Allerheiligen frei wir nicht wir müssen
arbeiten Harry Potter gehört einfach zu
Halloween und zum Herbst und bevor ich
jetzt noch zu oft Harry Potter sage
dieses Video ist nicht gesponsert von
Harry Potter aber von Emma und jetzt
alle dieses Video ist nicht gespan von
Harry Potter aber von Emma wo schaue ich
mein Harry Potter Marathon am liebsten
natürlich im Bett ich mache es mir
richtig schön gemütlich mach mir noch
eine Kerze an es gibt noch ein Tee dazu
und dann wird sich da ein abgemuckelt
abgemuggelt ein abgemuggelt und ich weiß
es ihr wisst es wir alle wissen es wir
verbringen viel Zeit im Bett nicht nur
wenn wir ein Harry Potter filmmarathon
machen sondern auch zum Schlafen und
deswegen ist ein guter Schlaf sehr
wichtig was gehört zu einem guten Schlaf
dazu die Qualität von deiner Matratze
deinem Bett deiner Bettdecke und deinem
Kissen ich schlafe jetzt schon sehr
lange mit den Produkten von Emma und
liebe mein flauschekissen den Topper und
meine Decke und vielleicht habt ihr es
ja auch mitbekommen wie ich das Zimmer
meiner Nichten umgestaltet habe und dort
habe ich den auch das Bett komplett mit
Emma Produkten ausgestattet und oh
Wunder sie lieben es auch mich hat's
nicht gewundert besonders die Matratze
ist bei denen sehr gut angekommen und
falls du jetzt gerade nicht auf der
Suche nach einem flauschekissen bist
kein Problem Emmer hat noch ganz viele
andere tolle Produkte Bettwäsche
gewichtsdecken ich habe mir jetzt gerade
eine gewichtsdecke bestellt ich warte
darauf dass sie kommt ich freue mich
übertrieben drauf schlafsup ist
boxpringbetten und und und die
Produktauswahl ist wirklich sehr groß
schaut doch einfach mal vorbei und wenn
ihr euch schon mal auf der Website
befindet dann benutzt doch einfach
meinen Rabattcode malwanne und ihr könnt
5% auf die Produkte sparen und Emma hat
sich dieses Jahr gedacht sie machen die
blackweek einfach mehrere Wochen lang
und da kann man teilweise 50% auf
Produkte noch mal on top sparen mit dem
5% Rabattcode und dann noch mal 50% also
schaut euch das alles mal in der Infobox
an mein Rabattcode ist sehr lange gültig
das seht ihr auch unten in der Infobox
und die blackweek geht bis zum 30.11
2023 viel Spaß beim ausstarten und jetzt
ihr kleinen hexenzauberer und Muggel
geht's weiter mit dem Video Harry Potter
Harry
Potter Skandal 7690 bei Amazon
8995 bei Elbenwald dieser Kalender
kostet zwischen 80 und 90 € habe ich
auch so viel dafür
bezahlt oh mein Gott ich habe
9485 bezahlt bei Elbenwald geht halt
einfach noch mal 5 € Versandkosten dazu
und der Kalender hat 89,95 gekostet ich
meine amazon hat eintageslieferung und
7690 also jetzt erwarte ich was ich habe
mich nicht spoilern lassen also so gut
es geht nicht spoilern lassen erster
Eindruck
cool jetzt muss ich erstmal gucken
ich finde den ersten Eindruck sehr
ach so der ist einfach aufgebaut wie so
ein Koffer ist ja auch das kofferdesign
und hier ist z.B eine 5 und dann ist
hier die 23 one also das ist so richtig
verschachtelt eingepackt aber ich sehe
nicht wie 24 Türchen drin sein sollen
ich bin so hyped Nummer 1 eine kleine
Schachtel hören wir doch auf sieht so
selbstgemacht
aus
wow also ich glaube ich bin es einfach
nicht gewohnt mal Harry Potter Merch in
der Hand zu haben der nicht Hal total
die blöde schlechte Qualität hat hier
ist sogar so eine Schutzfolie drauf ist
das ein funktionierendes
Schloss what wie cool ist das okay es
ist vielleicht nicht das höchste
Sicherheitsschloss
aber ich liebe es oh mein Gott das ist
eine wunderschöne Kette so euer kleines
Tagebuch oder so dann tragt i mal euren
Schlüssel für euer
Tagebuch okay Nummer
Z oh mein Gott i love
it ey aufmachen zumachen das ist einfach
eine chrisbaumkugel die man als Geschenk
also du kannst damit halt noch was
verschenken ich würde sie niemals im
Leben verschenken oder man macht da
irgendwas rein ich wüsste jetzt aber
auch nicht was wenn man nur wenn man es
verschenken würde tolles Design tolle
Kugel ich häng sie mir mit Stolz und
Freude auf meinen Baum es sind 90 € ich
bleib natürlich kritisch und überhaupt
nicht
voreingenommen na klar so jetzt dürfen
wir mal hier an so ein Röhrchen ran
Nummer 3 ich weiß nicht wieso aber das
wirkt halt wirklich als ob das so ein Z
Girl irgendwie Selb eingepackt hat nur
dass die Qualität halt auch noch mal so
geisteskrank gut
ist ganz ehrlich das ist das was ich
sonst so an Harry Potter Merch
Adventskalender sehe das ist ja fühlt
sich Hal so nach so sehr einfachen
Plastik an ihr werdet mich jetzt auch
hassen ich weiß nicht was dieses P
bedeutet was bedeutet dieses P Leute das
W jetzt natürlich fail wenn er nicht
schreiben würde ne er hört sich ne das
ist das erste Produkt wo ich sag ne das
hört sich so billig an das ist irgendwie
total nervig beim Schreiben
Harry Potter schreib wunderbar Nummer 4
die sind echt
groß das riecht sehr nach Chemie mit
Motive drauf
ah ja okay auf diesem scrunchy sind
typische Harry Potter Motive drauf aber
so designed dass es nicht auf dem ersten
Blick aussieht wie hey ich habe ein
scrunchy mit Harry Potter Motiven drauf
also die Qualität von dem Ding ist sehr
gut aber der Geruch ist Minuspunkt
Nummer 5 ich weiß nicht was ein hier
erwartet oh
moment
auch ein
Baumanhänger ravenca love it ich bin
ravenca brauche ich in meinem Leben aber
ich weiß nicht genau was es ist von der
Qualität brauchen wir nicht sagen das
ist wirklich sehr hochwertig so
hochwertig wie so ein merchel halt sein
kann warum haben sie diese Schnalle
nicht auf dem Kopf gemacht das hängt
jetzt so ein bisschen so schief
das weiß ich nicht nicht so hübsch jetzt
kommt Nikolaus ich vermute mal nicht
dass die Wizarding World sich daran hält
Nummer
Nikolaus
ich kann es nur immer wieder sagen es
wirkt als ob das jemand eine
Privatperson eingepackt
hätte love Potion ach so love Potion die
sind aber Glitz klein ja halt Metall ne
sind Glitzer hier noch gut esert ein
bisschen glitzerp die wer ich
wahrscheinlich nicht tren können oh sind
die süß ich habe lange nicht solche
Ohrringe getragen ich sag ganz ehrlich
seit den Paul Valentine Kalender sind
meine Ohren bisschen verletzt
love Potion so Nummer
7 in Nummer 7 ist noch ein
Kugelschreiber noch ein
Kugelschreiber damit haben sie kein
Gefallen getan super nervig
irgendwie Nummer
was der Kalender hat stark angefangen
und stand nachgelassen das ist Hänger
Kugel mit einem Loch in der Mitte ja
okay jetzt kommt Türchen Nummer ne mein
absolutes lieblingstüchen und das beste
Türchen in diesem ganzen
Kalender
ja oh das Design ist wieder schön ist
halt ein Schlüssel anhängen ja ist ein
Schlüsselband ne davon kann man genug
brauchen nee was ist das denn ich sag ja
stark angefangen und dann nachgelassen
diese Seite sehr hübsch toll bedruckt
Luna loveg sieht man erkennt man
wunderbar und das hier ist irgendwie so
ein Druckfehler entweder ist es
Druckfehler oder es ist nass geworden
oder ich weiß nicht es sieht auf jeden
Fall sehr hässlich verschmiert aus ja
sonst also wäre es ein schönes Design
gewesen es macht es ja dann irgendwie
voll kaputt also übelst kaputt das sieht
rtig verwaschen aus aber der Druck ist
einfach der das hat sich irgendwie
bewegt dieses Bändchen und dann ist der
Druck schlecht geworden ich sag ja
bestes Türchen weiß ich nicht diger
Nummer 10 soll Auspacken das hat hier
jemand mit einem Papier umgewickelt und
dann so ein teser drauf gemacht
ja Bleistift mit so sehr süßen Harry
Potter Motiven Harry Potter auf cute
Dobby ja ein Bleistift Bleistift ist
Bleistift ne Nummer 11 ich weiß nicht
wie das sein kann dass hier so viele
Türchen drin sind und man so wen ich
eigentlich sieht noch so ein Anhänger
für für etwas was wir nicht haben
h schönes Motiv aber ja vielleicht
kriegen wir noch eine Kette oder so
vielleicht hätten wir die Kette ein
bisschen früher kriegen sollen das hier
ist ein bisschen ja Anhänger Halbzeit
Nummer 12 und wir haben einfach hier
noch genug Türchen wieder mal schön
selbst eingepackt das hat Daniel rliff
ganz frst
persönlich sich drum gekümmert
exp
ja guck doch mal das sieht doch cool aus
ja kan Lesen dieser Kalender macht echt
Spaß ich sag's euch
13 also auch wenn man manchm
Schwierigkeiten mit den Türchen hat ist
es trotzdem von den Türchen sehr gut
gemacht ein bten du
mus hat man Buton früher mal richtig
getragen ich habe sie an mein schulr
gemacht macht man das heutzutage noch
Computer sagt nein für 90 € will ich
kein Button sage ich ganz ehrlich 90 €
will ich kein B aber okay es ist halt so
überteuert ne also auch wenn man Merch
sich kaufen möchte das sind ja Preise
Katastrophe dein da sind auch noch
Türchen okay jetzt verstehe ich das das
ist wie Hermines Handtasche wenn du
reingreifst du merkst da ist noch viel
mehr los als man auf dem ersten Blick
dachte 14 aber jedes Türchen kann ja
nicht auch ein absoluter ber sein das
wäre ja auch unrealistisch
oder da ist es das verschollene Diadem
von ravencla nein endlich der die Kette
hier ist ein ganz kleiner Mechanismus wo
man den so aufkriegen kann wenn man
nicht so gottlos lange Fingernägel hat
wie
ich Acrylnägel sind einfach nicht das
Wahre ne du ich sag dir für ein Alltag
ist es einfach nicht
gemacht
ja so da können wir unsere Dinger da
rein machen ganz einfach also für manche
Dinge braucht man andere Menschen
alleine würde man sterben scheiße jetzt
habe ich natürlich falsch gemacht ist
doch wieder klar ja ich habe hier wieder
das Problem mit meinem dünnen Handgelenk
aber an sich ist es eine schöne Idee 15
W noch so ein Anhänger für dieses
Armband ich habe es gerade auf und zu
gekriegt natürlich noch so eine Kugel
also diese Kugeln expeliamus ich habe
schon eine Klammer mit expeliamus warum
muss ich den noch expelamus jetzt und
jetzt muss ich das da auf ich werde das
niemals im Leben alleine aufkriegen ne
mit lang Fingernägeln kann man alles
ganz genauso machen wie mit kurzen ja am
Arsch kann man halt nicht ja noch ein
Anhänger ich krieg das jetzt kriegt auch
manchm so ein beklemmendes Gefühl wenn
ihr etwas nicht von eurem Körper
wegkriegt es ist okay
W und W jetzt brauch ich noch mal
super intens was ist das was ist das H
ist das ein ich würde jetzt sagen das
ist ein Lesezeichen oder ja Lesezeichen
aus Metall nee das ist kein Lesezeichen
was soll sonst sein das ist flach und
lang und so vi Lesezeichen der Kalender
soll einen Wert von 130 P an jeury und
Accessoires haben 130 P ist eine Aussage
in der 17 ah ich weiß nicht ich habe ein
Gefühl das wird hier schon wieder dieser
Anhänger sein oh ne irgendwie blöd aber
irgendwie auch nee süß we die Sachen
müssen ja auch nüz sein ne und so ein
Haargummi Haargummi wo so ein kleiner
Zauberhut dran
ist können wir mal über das Design
sprechen dass die Zahlen da nicht
einfach drauf stehen sondern dann steht
da Potion Nummer 18 hier steht nur die
Zahl drauf aber bei den meisten ist es
irgendwie sehr schön eingebunden also
optisch hat sich da jemand dieses Jahr
richtig was
überlegt ST der Zauber damit man dumm
wird stupefy was soll ich dazu sagen
Nummer 18 19
noch eine Kette ja Qualität ist okay
sieht nicht allzu billig aus das ist
jetzt die Frage das ist jetzt halt so
ein schlichter hexenkelch es ist dann
halt neutraler ne dann so ein bisschen
he ich bin eine Hexe aber so ein
kochkesselkelch ein Kessel ja würde ich
den tragen ja damit zeige ich halt dass
ich eine Hexe bin ne sind ja also halt
auch eher so eine spaßkette ne wenn man
den Kalender auspackt ist es ja Dezember
das heißt bis zu Halloween dauert's noch
also wenn man sowas dann zu Halloween
anziehen möchte und sagen möchte guck
mal ich bin eine Hexe aber der
hexentrend ist ja auch so auch da find
es aber sehr positiv was für eine
Qualität der Schmuck hat also das ist
wirklich jetzt kein teurer Schmuck aber
es ist auch nicht billig verarbeitet 20
werde es niemals so zurück
reinkriegen ne lass mal das Design ist
ja ganz schön ne aber ich vergesse ich
glaube ich habe halt nicht auf dem
Schirm wie teuer so Merch ist
21 da wird do wieder so eine
schmuckkugel da drin sein ich spürre es
do schon wieder dass ich nichts fühle
heißt schon wieder dass da irgend so ein
Anhänger dran sein wird oh
ha der passende Armreif zu meinen
Ohrring das ist wirklich jetzt gewing 12
Jahre alt viele Sachen genben hier so
ein bisschen 12 Jahre alt aber ja 22
okay ich habe keine Ahnung was das sein
soll a und sie haben das gleiche Design
hierfür genommen das ist das einzige
Design was ich wiederholt was ist das
schreibt mir mal sehr gerne in die
Kommentare was das sein soll ich bin
super verwirrt Lesezeichen es ist ein
Lesezeichen ich sage es ist ein
Lesezeichen 23 vorletztes Türchen ich
bin noch nicht breit ich will noch mehr
Auspacken natürlich kann so ein Kalender
nicht überleben ohne einmal die
Heiligtümer des Todes irgendwie optisch
aufzugreifen das ist ja absolut klar
aber diese Art von Armband ja es ist
cute ja doch es jetzt gefällt mir
irgendwie es ist es ist schon hübsch ich
glaube es ist halt einfach nicht mein
Stil so aber ich kenne viele die halt
solche armbände einfach tragen ich
glaube da ist dann halt auch schön
Wolfgang Petri gucken Sie mal
hier und jetzt ist es Weihnachten wir
gehen zu unserem Adventskalender und
machen das letzte Türchen auf oh wisst
ihr was mich aber wundert dieser
Adventskalender muss ja aus England
irgendwie kommen und dass der nur 24
Türchen hat ist komisch weil immer wenn
ich Adventskalender aus England auspacke
haben die 26 Türchen weil bei denen so
Christmas ja richtig erst am 25
bei uns auch aber heiligabend ist bei
uns einfach
mehr hier noch mal wow tolles Design
24 na ja doch schön ein Felix
felizes Schlüsselanhänger ich würde bei
anderen Kalendern FE ich das doof sage
ich ganz ehrlich aber hier ist es
wirklich die gute Qualität es ist
hochwertig es ist echter Merch und halt
nicht das was ich oft schon ausgepackt
habe dieses nach Art von Harry Potter
und so oh ich bin hin und her gerissen
oh ich weiß viele von euch werden jetzt
in die Kommentare schreiben Vanessa
dieser Kalender ist Trash das sind ja
hier Pins und so ich glaube sie haben
mich mit diesem blöden Schloss und
Schlüssel am Anfang haben die mich auf
so eine pferte gebracht dass ich den
mega cool fand und dann habe ich ganz
gedacht der ist mega
cool und
eigentlich
ich habe gerade ein ganzes Fazit gemacht
und habe dann gesehen dass mein Mikrofon
aus war und das nichts davon aufgenommen
hat und dann habe ich Mittag gegessen
und habe gewartet dass dieses Ding
wieder auflät und jetzt muss ich darüber
sprechen was ich vor einer Stunde
gefühlt habe was ich zuerst sagen will
dieser Kalender ist wirklich Herz
allerliebst aufgebaut das habe ich noch
nie vorher bei einem Kalender gesehen
wie viel Detail und Ideen reingeflossen
sind um das wirklich eine ganz besondere
experience zu machen also mit den
verschiedenen Schachteln mit den Reagenz
mit den kleinen Flaschen da wurde sich
richtig was überlegt und ich finde die
Aufmachung ist schon mal wirklich eine
Zeh von ze was einem wirklich ein gutes
Gefühl für diesen Kalender gibt und die
Produkte sind auch toll also ich hatte
bis jetzt ja immer nur Fake oder nicht
original Harry Potter Merch Artikel und
oft waren es dann halt so Sachen wo man
dachte ja ist es ganz nett aber
irgendwie auch einfach schlecht
verarbeitet und das Gefühl hat man hier
finde ich gar nicht alles hat wirklich
eine gute Verarbeitung außer diese diese
stiftte die ziehen das ganze wirklich
runter und jetzt denke ich mir warum
sage ich aber nicht dass dieser Kalender
super toll ist zuerst weil er 90 €
kostet also das ist ein Preis das ist
viel und da hat man einfach Erwartungen
meine Erwartungen wurden teilweise
erfüllt mit diesem coolen Ding ich flipp
einfach immer noch aus wie gut das
funktioniert und wie schön das
verarbeitet ist und einfach die also ein
Schlüssel an seinem Hals zu tragen für
irgendwas geheimnisvolles was man sich
so ne verschließt ist einfach cool ich
habe aber die Lösung warum ich nicht
100% sage dass mir der gefällt und ich
den weiterempfehlen würde weil ich nicht
die Zielgruppe bin ich merke dass dieser
Kalender für eine jüngere Zielgruppe ist
also wenn ich 13 gewesen wäre dann wäre
das wirklich der absolute Oberkracher
mit 14 hätte ich mich vielleicht zu cool
gefühlt wenn ihr jetzt älter seid und
euch das alles sehr gut gefällt dann ist
es natürlich auch top aber ich sag nur
ich heute würde die Artikel halt nicht
so feiern weil vieles jetzt im Schranken
landen würde und ich damit halt nicht
viel anfangen kann trotzdem ist es ein
guter Kalender ich sehe nicht 90 € oder
130 P liegt aber auch daran dass ich
allgemein bei den Merch Artikeln von
Harry Potter jetzt z.B den Preis den sie
da verlangen e auch nicht sehe
vielleicht sind Ihre Preise
gerechtfertigt ich kenne die
Produktionsbedingungen nicht deswegen ja
kann ich dazu einfach nicht viel sagen
ich persönlich würde aber nicht das Geld
dafür bezahlen trotzdem sind paar
wirklich sehr schöne Artikel dabei die
ich gerne mag und dann müsst ihr das für
euch selber entscheiden wie ihr das
findet wenn es nur darum geht 10 von ze
wie praktisch man kann hier gleich alles
reinmachen
ich bin sehr gespannt was ihr zu diesem
Kalender sagt und wir sehen uns dann das
nächste mal wieder zu einem anderen
Adventskalender Unboxing ne in zwei
Tagen bis dann